as like entrepreneurs are kind of build
out their their a ecommerce business
it's really important to understand the
impact mobile devices has like had on
Commerce in general for a long time it
was it always thought that purchasing on
a mobile phone can't happen like you
have to like type in all this extra
information but more and more it's
becoming really obvious that like that's
where people are spending all their time
and so like in the same way people were
hopping online on their PCs like a long
time ago now a lot of that converse
happens on the phone and so it's really
important to like really think about how
do you optimize your experience and your
purchase experience specifically for the
mobile device and so things like
thinking about how can you autofill
information based off of what's already
in your phone built in there I'm and you
know and I'm like thinking about like as
you're actually have different
interactions with your with your website
thinking about like what how much how
much space do I actually have on the
screen like to actually fit in all the
different buttons like if you want to
have if you want to offer reviews like
ability to choose color ability to
choose size like ability to sort of
switch between a lot of different images
of the same product one of the things
that you realize is that and you have to
make trade-offs and the only way you can
really understand how to make those
trade-offs is is through testing and
kind of like really figuring out like if
I have this button here on which like
takes up the full screen or opposed to
like having having two different buttons
on that screen like how does that impact
the conversion rate and and so kind of
because of the focus more and more on
the mobile device like testing becomes
more and more important because you
don't have all that much real estate to
actually work with